The joe rogan experience.
What the fuck,
man,
we're a weird,
so weird.
What a stupid culture.
What are you doing?
I can't stop thinking about the guy,
the farted at the sink at the airport.
We talked about it for 10 minutes afterwards.
Dudes Fart when they pee and then go to the bathroom.
Constantly far to in public restrooms.
Yeah.
But we were at the sink and the dude was washing his hands and he cut a monster
fart.
And I told Tommy about it and I was like,
dude,
this guy,
he broke.
He broke the rules.
Yeah.
I walked out just before this happened.
I unfortunately missed the incident,
but you said it immediately and I was,
I kept wrapping my head around it and I think what I've come to the conclusion
is that if you do that,
all I'm looking for is for you to acknowledge it.
Oops.
Yeah.
You need to say something.
I want you to say something about that because I was thinking about how,
uh,
an old guy one time farted next to me in,
um,
uh,
like on a tram and then the airport.
And I was like,
Jesus,
he led a fucking pretty big fart.
And I looked at him and he goes,
snuck out of me.
I was like,
all right.
And I kind of took away like,
you know what was upsetting him that yes.
I was like,
well thank you for acknowledging your,
you're fart right now.
Yeah.
This guy was just washing his hands and he just,
the sink is not the year.
I don't think they get a pass there.
Yeah,
it was.
It was.
Definitely are know who does that to you?
It was definitely a gray area.
It was definitely a greater,
people fart all the time at the urinals.
That's so common.
Yeah.
I hear a lot of farms get done zip up walk all the way around and washing your
hands in the middle of Washington as you just unload and no one said a word.
Yeah,
everyone just,
just let it go and then we got outside.
I was like,
Yo Dude,
how do you feel about this?
I can't stop thinking of that.
And then we're trying to figure out what kind of farts girls cut when they're in
the bathroom and whether or not they washed their hands before nine each other.
Probably not as much.
Not as much,
but they definitely drop heat in there.
Once they close that door or then they allow themselves.
Yeah,
they allow themselves to,
to fucking farted up,
let me know.
You know,
they really let them rip.
Yeah.
Once they get in that door that closed that door,
they just,
you have to,
if you're taking a shit,
you got to Fart.
But I wonder if they fart while they're washing their hands.
These are the things that I think of it.
Yeah,
absolutely.
I wonder about what we need and the more of this moral,
do you mask your farts when you should shit in a public restaurant?
No.
Let it out.
You gotta do what you want to hold up
an idiot.
She's Jesus Christ.
You have it on your phone.
I love girl farts.
40 year old man.
He's got it on his phone.
Oh,
it's a huge fetish now.
That's actually a website.
It is.
It's amazing.
It always been.
Yeah,
it's amazing.
There's been far porn forever.
We're dudes like sniff farts,
whatever girl's ass.
I said,
naughty.
We played some a fart clips on our show and we were talking about it and the guy
wrote in and he was like,
I have a big time fart fetish.
And were what?
Like what's the thinking about it?
And he was like,
I think it's just back to the taboo of it that the pretty girl is not supposed
to.
So he's uh,
you know what I mean?
Like that it's,
yeah.
To be in a dirty girl and he loves,
you know,
a pretty girl doing it is like the ultimate thing.
Yeah.
That's the thing about people's,
like they want people to be naughty,
right.
Just because we feel so,
most people at least feel so confined by the rules.
And I think women,
so even more so than men,
women even more so than men because,
you know,
society wants you to be a lady and he wants a certain way.
Sure.
You know,
and they're slut shaming.
You're not allowed to be a slut.
You're not allowed to do what you want to do.
You know,
like if a woman wants to go out and fuck a bunch of different guys,
like w have one once a fuck,
two guys in a night,
she's a terrible person.
Like if you find out about that,
oh my God,
she and she went to this guy's house,
she fucked him.
Then she laughed and she went to this other guy's house and fucked him.
What a whore national champion.
Like girls would be like,
what a whore.
But if you told me,
so he decides he leaves his,
this girl's house and he's like,
you know what?
Fuck I can call somebody else.
You call somebody else.
And he goes and fucks her.
And we were like,
great,
you guys an animal.
It wasn't,
it wasn't even done yet.
Wanted to fuck more than,
that is crazy though that we don't,
you know,
that we have that,
that double standard for that.
I mean,
I remember in college a Guy,
a friend,
uh,
going into a sorority house and banging girls in the same house,
in the same nine different rooms and like,
yeah,
we all were like,
that's fantastic.
You're such a hero like yours.
Like we were all so happy with his story.
But if a girl went to a fraternity house,
fuck one guy said goodnight,
honey laughed and then knock the door,
man,
she's fucking under our attorney fucking whore.
Yeah,
we really should applaud her.
You mean?
Well or not,
you know,
either way we should let her do whatever she wants to do.
Yeah.
She just fucking people.
Why do you,
what do you care?
Are they going to stay together forever?
They're in college.
Jesus Christ.
If you have a problem with a grower,
will fucks one guy and then fucks not the guy that night.
You're silly.
Yeah,
you are.
What's wrong?
Could be one of those guys.
All you gotta do is throw your deck in front of her.
Obviously she likes him.
So that suppression leads to,
uh,
like a reaction is just holding back leads to this need to let it go.
And the girl just forks right in that dude's face guys.
Like if you did,
did you dirty bitch dirty farty bitch,
I'm a 40 bitch.
Pardon my mouth.
It's so funny,
the people that own this,
I love girlfriends are actually Watson right now.
I'm from out that it's all stupid.
Oh my gosh,
that's not Canada.
Me and I'm a bad girl.
The smell and the fucking noise and the whole thing that naughtiness of it all.
We hold it in Boston girls fighting.
We have a thing about,
um,
about people shitting too,
you know,
like no one wants to admit they just took a shit.
We want to hide it and get over it up with noise and fans and we want to light
matches and yeah,
it,
it is weird.
I mean,
I don't like,
uh,
the single single stall Unisex bathrooms.
When you got to shit,
I got shit.
And then there's like,
someone's like,
you're going in there and you're like,
ah fuck man,
why don't you go in first?
I know I get,
but you get that,
you know,
like I feel like I can't relax or you can say,
can I please use the restroom?
If you're at a meeting,
if you're having a meeting or something like that and you say,
I'll be right back off to use the restroom.
But you can't say,
look,
I've got to shit.
I gotta I can't keep talking to you guys.
I gotta take a shit.
You say I use the restroom.
It's ambiguous.
Okay,
go ahead.
Yeah.
And you leave,
you know,
you can't say,
I'm so sorry I was late for this meeting.
I got here on time,
but I had to shit.
Yeah,
right,
right.
You can't say that I would be upset.
You've got to go to the restroom and then you,
you know that the clock's running.
So,
cause if you come back 15 minutes later it covered in sweat.
They're like,
wow,
you took a monster shit.
Huh?
Like you can't really put that out there.
You're like,
oh fuck,
now I got to grind this thing out quick.
Sometimes that's what you have to do.
Sometimes you have to take a 10 minute heater.
Like sometimes you just,
you take a shit and it comes up clump,
clump,
and you're like,
God,
there's a lot more up there.
God dammit happened on the flight yesterday.
Oh No.
As soon as I sat down and was one of them wanting to go to sleep and I was like,
I gotta take a shit.
And it was during takeoff.
So then you're like waiting for it to hit 10,000 feet,
you know,
and then you're,
you're waiting for them to turn the seatbelt sign off.
And I go in there like,
this is going to be,
this is like a fucking marathon shit.
But I didn't have time for it,
so I really dropped half of it off just like a fall asleep.
Oh No.
And then later on I finished.
It was,
it was pretty,
pretty dramatic.
It's one of the weird things about your body is that there's like this
intangible sense of how much shit is in there.
You know,
like when you're taking a shit,
like you have that feeling,
that weird feeling like I smell a shit or I feel shit bro and I feel a shit
cooking in the oven.
And then once you're taking that shit you got this pressure thing like you know
it's in there and you know what's up there and there's a certain amount like God
damn it,
this isn't ready.
This is his diet it.
Yeah.
All right.
I'm going to have to,
I'm going to have to up to empty it and then I'll come back later.
Yeah.
And that's,
and that's the worst you'd like when it's all gone.
Yeah.
Certain foods to will trigger just amazing amounts of shit.
The commodity you where you're just like,
is my body mostly shit?
Like am I just a walking talking shit machine?
Because sometimes I'll like,
the amount that will come out of me is just incredible to me.
I cannot get over what's coming out of me.
If you think about how much food you eat though,
if you sink,
sink,
think of like the your entire day.
If you shit once a day thinking about breakfast in there and then lunch in there
and then your dinner in there,
like this giant mound of food that goes into your body and then snack,
like you might have a protein bar along the way and then you'll have all this
you drink thing.
He might drink milk which has got some solids in there and then slowly but
surely compress that into just laws.
Big ropey shit logs.
It's amazing.
It's not really bigger.
Now picture a pretty girl squatting over your face and letting that all over
you.
Ooh,
well that's a under glass like big thing.
People guys coffee from guys like women shitting on class coffee tables.
Yeah,
I mean I always heard that about Stallone.
Those,
those like one of those rumors probably made up.
It's probably like the Richard Gere durable thing.
Yeah.
Someone decided to to say it and then it sounds cool.
So people are repeat it.
Yeah,
it was still own likes.
She likes to get under tables and girls take big juicy shifts on those tables.
She loves him cause you want to fuck them.
Just wants them to shit.
I'd like to watch people,
Shit.
It's over a glass table just to see it come out.
Maybe once for sure.
What about a guy like Joey Diaz,
which I think that's the one that would be at the top of my list.
What if he fell and landed on a table on the table shattered and you died.
That'd be horrible.
Class went through.
Your next shit was in your eyeballs and you'd died knowing that shit was all
over your face and feeling the,
the hot blood rush out of your neck.
Wow.
I slept at too much sodium.
I think that it would be much more interesting to watch the shit.
Then some model.
I'd like to see him have explosive diarrhea on a glass table.
Well,
I would like to see a girl who's like addicted to stimulants,
like who's trying to be really skinny.
How just how little she actually shifts my hair comes out.
Probably shocking to see like a little tiny poops.
Curly squarely turned slightly bile.
The yellow smell to it.
Like what's going on?
Yeah.
Sorry.
That's a big one.
Anything.
Half of her shit,
his pills,
how do come out?
Yeah.
Like non dissolved pills.
Clumps.
Yeah.
But I mean it would be fun to watch a couple of times.
Maybe Watch,
I don't know about fun,
but maybe fascinating.
Fascinating.
I think as an art exhibit,
you know,
we're talking about art allows weekend,
it'd be great to set up a live exhibit.
I've always thought of this where you have like 10 people 50 feet up and their
button naked and they have different body types and they're sitting on glass
toilets with glass tubes coming down.
And then the exhibit as you walk around and they all shit,
like that'd be kind of fun.
And they flush it and you see these glass tubes fill up with shit and come
tumbling down.
And then you do a septic at the bottom,
a giant large tank filled with shit that's all glass.
And you have different colored hair and you're like,
I,
this is my creation.
this is,
if you wanted to buy this,
it's five 15 minutes.
Yeah.